Well,
mainstream media focuses on trump's
locker room talk and Clinton's emails.
There are actually a whole slew of other
interesting political stories happening
right now related to the presidential
election.
This election has seen a massive shift
in America's political alignment on both
the left and the right on the left.
We've seen a real divide between the
Bernie wing of the Democrats and the
Clinton camp.
Bernie's message against Wall Street
money in politics,
and his chastising of the political
establishment has been swallowed whole
by the Political Clinton machine.
While Bernie is now supporting Hillary,
it's pretty clear that many of his
supporters aren't following his lead in
either donations or enthusiasm.
This division is one of the reasons
hillary is still struggling with young
people and overall connecting with new
voters.
Meanwhile,
on the right,
we've seen the absolute fracturing of
the Republican Party as we know it.
Mainstream Republicans like Paul Ryan,
John Mccain,
and Jeb Bush are now on the outside
looking in.
As trump has aggressively gutted the
party.
It's pretty clear that if trump wins in
November,
the old guard of the Republicans will be
out and his inside circle of people like
Rudy Giuliani,
Chris Christie,
and Ben Carson will be in while the list
of Republicans not voting for trump
continues to grow.
The Republican base who voted during the
primaries is still with him and whether
the party is supporting trump or not,
those people are trump's rise also
fractured.
The Republican Party ideologically
neo-cons are either and hiding,
are defecting to Hillary.
While the Christian conservatives are
backing trump,
a candidate who is probably their last
choice when this election began.
Let's not forget,
this is a guy who compared his own book
to the Bible as they say,
politics makes strange bedfellows for
both the Democrats and the Republicans.
Twenty 16 will be looked back on as a
watershed year regardless of who wins.
It's clear the parties are in flux and
they both desperately need new ideas and
new leaders.
The fact that we have a 69 year old
Democrat running against a 70 year old
Republican tells you all you need to
know about the aging state.
Of our two party system,
how is it that these two were the best?
Our system can churn out while it's easy
to mock millennials,
just imagine how you would feel if this
was the first presidential election you
ever really paid attention to or had a
chance to vote it.
We've got the ultimate reality star
running against the ultimate insider,
and while they may hate each other,
they are also perfect for each other.
By the time this thing is over,
they'll have thrown out everything but
the kitchen sink,
but that'll only be because they needed
it to wash their dirty hands.
One of the many issues which seems to
have been almost totally shelved during
this campaign is science.
I guess in some ways science is the
obvious sacrificial lamb in an election
contest focusing so much on mudslinging
instead of discussing the actual issues
that affect our lives.
As we discussed during my chat with
transhumanist is all time van two weeks
ago.
There are so many huge upcoming
scientific breakthroughs coming down the
pike from stem cell research to cloning
to artificial intelligence that we must
talk about these issues now so that
we'll know how to deal with the
ramifications of them both good and bad
when they're right in front of us.
Scientific breakthroughs will continue
to happen,
whether we're prepared for them or not.
Perhaps we can never be fully prepared,
but we at least need leaders who believe
in the merits of science in the first
place.
My guest this week is theoretical
physicists,
Lawrence Krauss Kraus,
the foundation professor in the school
of Earth and space exploration and
Physics Department at Arizona State
University,
as well as the director of the origins
project at Asu,
which focuses on the origins of humans
and the universe itself.
Cross has been outspoken this election
related to politics and science,
particularly the seeming lack of
knowledge in this department by Donald
Trump.
We're going to dive deep both into
science and politics as well as the many
places that the two intersect.
I figure if a guy can spend his adult
life trying to figure out the mysteries
of the universe,
then maybe just maybe he can figure out
the mysteries of our current political
existential crisis.
Joining me this week is an author,
a theoretical physicist,
and a professor at the school of Earth
and space exploration at Arizona State
University.
Lawrence Krauss.
Welcome to the Rubin [inaudible].
It's great to be here.
You are in the middle of like 8,000
things and we're going to have to use
some theoretical physics to fit this in
the time space time continuum.
Eighty thousand plus or minus a million.
Yeah.
Plus or minus a million.
All right.
Well I'm very excited to talk to you.
I think I publicly shamed you into doing
this several times at the reason rally.
Yeah.
Well it's hard to publicly shame me,
but you did try.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
but I wanted to do it.
It's just a matter of fitting in and
it's great that we can be here today.
Yeah.
All right.
So I'm very excited you're heading to
ucla to do some more talk to after this,
but let's,
let's jump right into the election
because I have to.
Maybe we'll talk about the science.
It's about,
you know,
why not as a man of science,
how do you feel about just the tenor of
this and,
and not just the tenor,
but as someone that cares about
empirical evidence,
they don't care about facts.
How do you feel about just the state of
what is going on right now?
It's every,
every year.
I always wonder if it could be worse
because you know,
let's face it,
politics and empirical evidence that
don't go together very well as a rule.
I know for a long time I've been
interested in trying to make sure public
policy is based on that and in a lot of
different ways in my writing and,
and we,
we actually created a group in 2008
called science debate,
which we tried to get a presidential
debate on issues of science and
technology.
Not to ask them to 10th digit of Pi,
but if the issues that really matter
that are gonna affect the future for
people are not the issues that ever
talked about,
their energy,
the environment,
security,
all of that depends on,
on,
on an understanding of science and
technology policy and so it's always
been ignored and we.
And we've been frustrated by it,
but I have to say that this is this
year,
of course with Donald trump takes the
cake in so many ways.
He's the.
I wrote a piece in the New Yorker which
more or less called them the anti
science candidate if such a thing as
possible.
The only person I think on the
Republican slate that was more anti
science remarkably was Ben Carson.
Right.
Let's just talk about Carson.
Really?
Yeah.
Why not?
Because he's such a fool.
How can you be?
He's an.
He's a neurosurgeon.
Neurosurgeon,
right.
How can you be a neurosurgeon and
against so many of the things that a
scientist as well,
not just against ignorant about them,
that that's what amazed me.
It's,
it's,
it's one thing to be I logic
ideologically opposed,
but he would talk about evolution away
which clear,
clean them under,
didn't understand evolution,
which is the basis of biology besides
calling the big bang a hoax from the
devil and all,
I mean just fat.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
that in fact we didn't land on the moon,
but uh,
uh,
but,
so what it demonstrates is,
and it's unfortunate,
but actually it's relevant.
My mother wanted me to be a doctor and,
and,
and she made the mistake of,
of sort of getting me interested in
science and wanted to be a scientist.
And then I discovered when I was in high
school that doctors weren't scientists.
I apologize to all doctors,
they're not.
And,
and he's a perfect example,
you to be,
to be a good that,
that's not to say how many doctors try
and keep up with science obviously,
but to be a good neurosurgeon requires
eye hand coordination and a,
and an understanding of what to what to
do when you open up a brain.
It's,
it.
I will get in trouble for saying this,
but it's a very sophisticated kind of
car mechanic and so he clearly was very
good at those technical things,
but obviously you don't.
Obviously he he not only did not know
much science,
but he he willfully,
and this is the real problem with with
religion it with someone like him,
he decides what's right based on the
scriptures and anything disagrees with
it must be wrong and that's that's the
real difference between religion and
science were in religion.
You know the answers before you ask the
questions and in science we try and ask
the questions and find out the answers
and they may surprise us and they may
change over the course of not only may
they often do and the willingness to say
you're wrong or to change your mind is
profoundly important in science.
Which brings us back to Donald Trump,
but real quick just to finish with
Carson because it's such an interesting
example of this.
I'm glad you made the distinction of
saying that he's a neurosurgeon.
Surgeon.
Scientists now fumbled twice.
It's okay because a neuroscientist has
to really have the scientific knowledge,
the way you're describing the souped up
car guy,
car mechanic.
It's like,
really?
He's doing,
he's doing a physical act.
He's,
he's repairing damage and,
and he needs to know how to do that.
And you know,
I,
again,
one doesn't want to generalize for all
neurosurgeons based on Ben Carson,
but it demonstrates that there's a
difference and he,
and I'm assuming he was good at what he
did and it wasn't all hype.
Uh,
I'm willing to grant him that,
but in everything else he says he
expressed more ignorance,
not just antagonism,
but ignorance about fundamental science
than any other candidate in the
Republican Party,
which says a lot because,
because they're,
you know,
they're,
it has unfortunately become the anti
science party of late and it wasn't
always that way.
There party has been a big supporter of
science over the years right now because
they insist on denying the existence of
climate change.
And many on the right insist on denying
the existence of evolution or even the
Big Bang,
uh,
and their,
their attitudes towards homosexuality.
They have necessity by ideology,
been forced to confront the evidence of
science and ignore it or,
or disregarded or or,
or lie about it,
right?
So basically they've staked out a
position based on non fact and then that
sort of boxes them in their own real
problem.
What do you do when you're wrong and you
can't afford to say wrong.
And the problem actually the real
problem with politics is people are not
willing to say,
you know what?
We have this policy but it was wrong.
We've changed our minds because it and,
and I read the public.
One of the reasons I want to have wanted
to insert more science into,
into public policy is not not the
knowledge of science,
but the process of science which is
based on empirical evidence and testing
and,
and evolving your views.
And if we really want to have sound
public policy,
we can't.
We can't just be willing to say,
oh well someone was wrong once and
therefore,
you know,
we're not going to listen to them
stating that you're wrong.
And explaining why is to me raises you
to a higher level.
Someone.
It's a beautiful thing,
in fact,
as a scientist often say as a
theoretical physicist,
I say the two greatest states to be in
our being wrong or confused because then
that means a lot more to learn.
Yeah.
There's a little room there for a of.
I mean,
I mean it's really learning is a process
of discovering errors and what you were
thinking.
And,
and uh,
I have often said,
in fact my new book,
I said somewhere that,
that science one of the purposes of
sciences to make people uncomfortable.
And I don't mean that in a bad sense,
but if we're always comfortable,
it means we're never going outside our
comfort zone.
It means are myopic.
Views are never been questioned or
confronted.
And that's what living is all about.
That's what mute music,
art literature all about.
I mean,
it's,
you know,
I'll bring in,
happens to be today.
I'm excited because Bob Dylan just won
the Nobel Prize in literature,
but you know,
people like Bob don't force us to
confront.
I remember when I was young,
our views about waste society worked and
science should be the same way.
And,
and good politicians should be,
should be all about that.
It's amazing to me when I've been in
some other countries and,
and,
and uh,
confronting,
um,
presidents or prime ministers who
actually who actually
no something.
And then that's,
you know,
that's not to say,
I mean Obama is a.
yeah.
Anyway,
I don't want to hate mail no matter
what.
You're going to get hate mail,
hate.
Well wait till you see what happens on
twitter.
But uh,
but we can talk about Obama and Clinton
too.
But interestingly,
it sounds like you're saying you don't
necessarily care if the,
if the president knows that much about
sites,
but you at least want them to be
intellectually curious enough to,
to assign the right people.
It looked.
The president can't be an expert in
everything,
but the president needs to know they're
not.
The first thing is to know you're not an
expert in everything,
which is Donald Trump hasn't yet figured
out.
And secondly,
to be intellectually curious and
thirdly,
to choose the right people.
That's really what you want a president
to do,
is have good advisors,
is to know enough to distinguish people
who are full of garbage.
I'll use that word.
Uh,
and,
and people you can trust who's opinions
you can trust because you know that
they're willing to be wrong too.
And so I think that's really the
president.
And uh,
and uh,
uh,
in,
in the current climate,
you obviously can't be an expert in
anything.
And an amazing me when we talk about,
you know,
having debate on science,
they say,
well,
the president shouldn't be a scientist,
but you know,
you know,
we have a debate on national security,
but with the president doesn't have to
be a military expert.
He has to be surrounded himself or
herself with,
with reasonable people who know what's
going on or,
or on diplomacy.
So is the intellectual curiosity part of
it,
is that the part that about trump gets
you the most?
Well,
it's intellectual curiosity and
skepticism.
Skepticism is a key part of science.
Be asking yourself,
is this evidence reasonable and why
should I believe that?
Yeah.
The the thing that,
it's hard to know what trump is such an
anomaly,
but the fact that when he says,
you know,
who do you take advice from?
He says for myself,
because I'm,
you know,
I know that are mad when when someone
says that no matter what they're running
for,
whether it's president or,
or,
uh,
or head of a school board or whatever,
you should worry about that.
And so I think it's that and his
incredible
anger and vindictiveness and you know,
people have called him a,
a bully,
but you know,
I did a,
I did a dialogue with the Hollywood
friend of mine named Johnny Depp and he
and he pointed out that wasn't who he
actually,
he actually played Donald Trump in it.
You should watch it on Netflix.
And it was a great show where he,
he looks just like him.
It's great.
But he said that Donald Trump isn't a
bully.
He's a brat.
And that,
that defines the man to me.
He's not a bully so much as just a
spoiled Brat.
Who,
who,
if he's losing,
finds a reason to blame other people.
It does.
Again,
he's the center of his own universe and
all of that is,
is,
uh,
is terrifying and uh,
and ignorant in the extreme.
I mean,
one of the,
when I wrote about science and,
and the candidates this year,
one of the statements that trump made
that just to me epitomizes the level of
ignorance of the man because first of
all,
a lot of what he says is just meant he
doesn't care whether it's true or not.
He thinks it'll play well or not.
That I can understand when you say,
you know,
why are we worried about the ozone?
Why can't I have know aerosols in my
hairspray because I only use my
hairspray indoors.
So it can affect,
can affect you that Mr said that now
that's the kind of thing you say.
Oh my goodness gracious.
So anyway,
yeah,
that one's tough.
So,
okay,
so we've got your feelings on trump,
I think.
I think they're clear,
right?
Yeah.
Well I have,
I've been trying to moderate them less,
uh,
um,
you know,
the p,
I just wrote a piece in the New Yorker
Today on,
on,
on the nuclear threat.
And,
and,
uh,
to be more serious,
his misunderstanding of,
of the fact that nuclear weapons are not
meant to be used.
And in fact,
the,
as I pointed out,
it demonstrates a lot of our,
of the illogical nature of our nuclear
policy.
But when he says,
if you're,
you know,
if we build them,
why can't we use them that anyone has
thought about it,
I realized that you can't,
you can't use them in any strategic way.
And so it's,
and if he wants to encourage other
countries to build them,
he,
he misunderstands the whole point of
proliferation and those things are
serious.
They're not,
you know,
we can't laugh over that stuff.
So I really tried and I think mostly
people that watch your show,
I really tried to be fair to him and,
and,
and whatever.
So when,
when he's talking about the nuclear
stuff,
and I'll say something like,
you know,
uh,
Japan should have nukes so that they
could defend themselves potentially from
China.
It seems to me that there's some grain
of truth in the,
in the concept of that,
that,
that we shouldn't have to feel like we
have to defend Japan.
Well,
you're saying it really throws off every
sort of preceptive how all these nations
have.
Well,
it prints rolls off the precept of,
of,
of really what we should be trying to do
with nuclear weapons,
which we isn't talked about enough
today,
which is we want to reduce the number of
nuclear weapons,
the world because there's really no good
use for the right eye.
And we built up this incredible stash of
nuclear weapons because of the Cold War
and we had this policy of mutually
assured destruction.
So we had to have enough to ensure that
total annihilation of the Soviet Union
when the Soviet Union.
And uh,
that's okay.
But we then have in,
even at the time of Nixon,
we signed the Nonproliferation Treaty.
Most people think the Nonproliferation
Treaty,
and this is so typical of the US,
is designed to say no one should have
nuclear weapons but us.
And that's not what it's about.
It's trying to say we don't want to have
nuclear weapons to spread,
but the other thing that the nuclear
nations agreed to in the
Nonproliferation Treaty was to disarm
and so we have an obligation.
We are violating the Nonproliferation
Treaty today in this country as much as
North Korea may be by trying to get
nuclear weapons are getting new weapons
or Iran,
which happily they've been stopped from
getting them for the moment because we
are not making an open effort.
Did it's arm and Obama who whose heart
was certainly the right place.
He said,
you know,
we see the world should,
should get rid of nuclear weapons,
and initially the,
the,
his administration actually did an,
an agreement with the Soviet Union with
the Russia to reduce the number of arms,
but we still have way too many.
We still have a thousand nuclear weapons
on hair trigger alert,
which means they can be launched
instantaneously if,
if there's a warning of an attack,
whether the warning is real or not.
The president only has a few minutes to
decide that is not necessary in the
modern world.
And also,
unfortunately,
and I'm happy to see that,
that Hillary Clinton seems to be against
it.
We are barking at a $1,000,000,000,000
modernization of nuclear weapons fleet,
which is only reasonable if we plan to
keep our nuclear weapons level at what
it is.
If we say no,
you know,
eventually want to reduce them.
We don't have to spend that much money
trying to maintain the arsenal we now
have.
And so it's interesting to me to see
that the nuclear issue,
which over time has been,
has raised and lowered in importance.
The public doesn't seem to think about
it,
but it is still the major threat,
the major existential threat to
civilization.
And,
and we as a country are not doing enough
and it is true at the same time that
we're probably going to this more than
you want to know.
But it's true that Russia is getting
more worrisome than they were afforded
the saber rattling the arguments about
nuclear weapons are much worse now under
Putin in the last few years.
And they were.
So there's some concerns in that regard.
But,
but,
um,
we could take unilateral steps which
would lead us in the right direction,
right?
So even if Russia was 10 times worse
than you might,
if we had half of our stockpile it,
we'd still be more than enough to
destroy.
If we had a 10th of our,
if we had a 10th of our stock pile,
we,
we could still not only annihilate the
Soviet Union,
but essentially create enough mess to
destroy the world.
And,
uh,
it,
we,
we need to,
we need to realize that fact and,
and,
and realize that we can,
as I say,
unilateral actions are often responded
to.
For example,
another area where we spend money that
we,
that's a waste of time for the most part
is missile defense.
When one of the things I love is a,
George Bush claimed that they were gonna
have a missile defense system ready in
2004.
He was during the election.
And,
and of course it turned out that most 50
percent of the American public thought
we already had one.
And as they was going at the time,
what they should say is we already have
one just as effective as this system
that doesn't work,
but it doesn't cost $100 million.
So it's a lot less expensive and,
and it serves the same effect.
So how much of this though is just that
a huge percentage of our economy is tied
into the military?
It is,
but you know the.
But what you're hearing in the president
of the election is we're not spending
enough.
And that's what scary.
What we need to do is spend rationally.
People said that for a long time,
you know,
we,
we spend almost a trillion dollars on
the,
on,
on defense every year.
And the question is we have to look and
say,
what are we need?
Look,
it's not as if we can disarm as a nation
completely in all ways the world is a
dangerous place.
But the question is,
do we need to spend that kind of money?
And the answer,
I think for many people as we could
spend less more effectively.
Do you think there's any situation where
ethically we could use nukes?
I mean,
if,
let's say,
because I don't think it's going to be
through a nation state,
but let's say they,
you know,
somebody got a dirty bomb in here and
blew up times square.
So the question is,
what do you,
I think the answer generally is no
nuclear weapons right now are useful for
deterrence to stop other people from
doing things,
but it is,
you hit an interesting point that,
that when might you use them and see
what many people may not realize is that
the country has no.
Most people think the US has a no first
use policy,
namely we would never be the first ones
using them.
We don't write that because we said,
well,
what if not someone who uses nuclear
weapons,
but what if someone launches biological
weapons?
You know,
shouldn't we be allowed to nuke them?
Or what if someone nukes South Korea
shouldn't be allowed to nuke and
response?
And so these are questions that you can
debate.
But uh,
on the whole,
the question is what,
what do you gain versus conventional
forces?
And you know,
other than active anger,
right?
If the act has already been done yet
here,
so the question is what do you,
the idea should be to stop that in the
future?
Uh,
not an and inevitably the problem is
that under many scenarios,
once you start using nuclear weapons,
the,
it proliferates and,
and what's been pointed out by a bunch
of his sister even bout 10 years ago,
you may remember nuclear winter with
Carl Sagan and that there was,
that was sort of discredited a little
bit,
but in fact even at a limited nuclear
war between India and Pakistan have 50
or a hundred weapons,
which may sound like a lot,
but it's the kind of thing you might
expect in a nuclear war would,
would raise enough basically dust in the
atmosphere to for a decade affect
agriculture.
Ultimately perhaps killing a billion
people through starvation.
So there's no such thing as a limited
nuclear war.
And,
and it,
and everyone,
including the right wing guys like
George Schultz and Henry Kissinger came
up a bunch of years ago and said,
we need to basically work towards a
nuclear free world because as long as we
have nuclear weapons,
we're all at risk.
So how do you untie that then from the
legitimate parts of deterrent?
If your argument is that deterrence is
an important piece of the strategy,
because might be by having deterrence,
you don't necessarily have to fight a
ground war.
How do you untie those?
Well,
for example,
well,
how many you can ask right now?
How many nuclear weapons you need to
deter a,
uh,
an aggressor and you certainly don't
need.
We,
the United States has $5,000
over the Russia.
Russia,
excuse me,
I grew up in the Soviet Union.
You forgetting what year it is?
Yeah.
I know Russia has Russia,
another $5,000.
That's,
you know,
we don't need 5,000
weapons to deter him.
100 nuclear weapons would be more than
enough to destroy basically any country
and,
and dramatically affect the world.
So maybe we could immediately go down to
a hundred weapons will be indifference
then ultimately for someone that's
hearing you and saying,
well if we haven't but we're not using,
what's the difference whether we have
$5,000
to maintain a fleet of a 5,000
weapons,
including the infrastructure requires an
incredible amount of money.
Got It.
So that alone,
in fact,
this $1,000,000,000,000
modernization gives you an example of
the infrastructure costs.
So there are economic costs as well as
security costs.
And if we decided rationally,
you know what?
It's better to know it.
It's like if you have 10 cars that cost
you a lot more money to maintain them,
then if you have one,
it's not just the cost of the cars.
Yeah.
So as a theoretical physicist,
when you talk about all of this stuff,
you have an insight into how things
actually work that the average person
doesn't have.
Do you worry that you'll ever stumble
upon something or you know,
somehow accidentally or maybe
intentionally you find something and
then realize how it can be turned into
something horrific.
I mean that's like the big apocalyptic.
I he not happily what I,
I'm always pleased to say that what I
work on has no practical significance
whatsoever.
I heard you say that,
but its origins and history of the
universe and,
and,
and uh,
you know,
you can never.
Of course,
the great thing about science is you
never know what's going to be discovered
or what the implications so that I
guess.
But if you had to pick one area that had
less direct practical significance,
you,
it'd be hard to find one that more than
mine,
which was where I try and understand how
the universe began and how it's going
end.
And these,
these questions are incredibly important
for us culturally,
but the but the kind of new physics that
we try and develop and understand
affects the universe on scales that
really are divorced from human scales
directly.
Obviously they,
they relate to what the reasons.
You know,
how we got here.
My new book,
which I will plug called the greatest
story ever told so far,
the subtitles on March 27th,
March 2017.
And it's.
But at the subtitle is called why are we
here?
And ultimately we want to understand
those questions and unfortunately,
religion tries to usurp those questions
that I want to point out how science can
dress them.
So their fundamental sort of cultural
questions.
But,
but I like to say,
although it's pretentious,
because I don't want to meet comparison,
but my work is,
the work by people like me is as useful
as a Mozart symphony.
I mean,
it's at its best at its best.
It can be as useful as a Mozart
symphony.
It enhances the cultural experience of
being human.
Um,
so I'm happily,
uh,
I'm not as worried about that,
but on the other hand,
what we need to do is for.
There's an old expression,
I think from Pesto,
but it could be from later on.
I never,
I've tried to track it down at fortune
favors the prepared mind and what we
need to do or think about what the
possibilities are.
So we're prepared to act and we can't be
prepared to act if we put our heads in
the sand so we can say,
oh,
we should never,
you know,
uh,
do genetic engineering.
But it's happening.
We w we,
so we can talk about artificial
intelligence and say we need to,
we need to stop that,
but it's not going to be stopped what we
need to do or think about the
possibilities.
And that's one of the reasons why the
origins project that run at Asu is so
for me,
so exciting because we try to bring
scientists together to look at forefront
questions,
but then we have public events were 3000
people attend and listen.
And the point is to,
you know,
you can't have a good democracy without
an informed population.
And,
and so to try and raise these questions
and get people to think about the
possibilities are,
will allow us to be better prepared for
an,
for surprising possibilities in the
future because we don't know where the
future lies.
Uh,
uh,
I,
I often say,
and I said it on a film recently that
I'm not.
If someone tells you they're a futurist
in my mind,
that's when he stopped listening because
I try not to make predictions about
anything other than like 2 trillion
years in the future because that's a.
What do you call that as a super future?
Well,
yeah,
because first of all,
no one will be around a test and it is
much easier but,
but,
but we don't discoveries are called
discoveries because there are surprises,
but we can try and at least anticipate
the set of possibilities so it will be a
little less surprised and all of us can
do that and that's why you know,
you say I'm a scientist and I have
access.
It's true.
I have access to some information people
don't normally have access to,
but the process of science we can all be
at least have a perspective of what's
happening and that's why it's important.
That's why I spend time in the public
hat trying to,
trying to explain and explore science
for the public,
not just because it's interesting and
exciting and it is.
It's fun and people are fascinated by
it,
but because hopefully it will be useful
when people try and confront the
challenges of the 21st century.
Alright.
So I want to spend the rest of this
talking about your actual work and
origins and stuff like that.
But my last question on this part,
I have no agenda but I know you don't.
You've made it very clear which I love
that.
So.
Well my last part goes to your public
happy because clearly you're,
you're willing to talk about politics,
you're willing to,
you know,
speak about things freely.
And as you emailed me,
I have no no agenda or anything.
Um,
do you ever fear that that will have a
professional cost just by saying things
quite already?
It does all the time,
but I suppose to some extent,
no,
I,
if I feared about that,
I would've stopped a long time ago.
I guess.
Look,
I think there's not a day goes by that I
don't realize I'm fortunate in a way
that people,
for one reason or another want to listen
to me,
or at least I have a public profile and
therefore I have a responsibility.
It seems to me to use that profile
responsibly.
And that means of course,
to try and,
uh,
and,
and popularized science in a way,
but also to try and do what I can to,
to have an impact.
So in some sense,
you know,
it goes hand in hand with what I said to
you about my work.
My work has no practical significance
whatsoever,
but I'm,
but as a human being,
I'm very political on.
I'm very interested in what's going on
and therefore in some sense,
maybe I make up for the fact that my
work has no usefulness by take advantage
of my public profile to try and,
and do useful things.
And one of the useful things can try and
be leased to provoke people to think
about these things.
And so,
uh,
that's what I do.
All right,
so now let's,
let's get into the work part of it.
Part that apparently has no meaning or
no,
it has lots of meaning but no
significance.
No one has significance in a global
sense,
in a cosmic sense and a in a,
in a,
in a existential sense,
but it doesn't,
it won't cause a better toaster.
Bob Built and you know,
that's one of the problems with science
is that it has practical utility.
It's obviously not a problem because we
couldn't be doing this show.
We wouldn't.
People wouldn't live as long as they
live.
All our modern society is based on the
results science,
but because science produces technology
that changed our lives,
people suddenly think that unless it's
related to the technology,
it's not an interesting.
Whereas I say art doesn't produce
anything practical so people don't
expect them to say,
you know what,
that Picasso painting hasn't produced
something that makes me live longer and,
but,
and so because science has that
practical side,
people forget the cultural side that
they,
the knowledge side and that's to me is
as important as anything.
What I've,
I've quoted a number of times and uh,
but I'll quote it again here,
one of my favorite statements from a guy
named Robert Wilson who was the director
of the first director of the National
Accelerator Laboratory,
which is a particle accelerator near
Chicago,
which accelerates particles to look at
fundamental structure matter.
It was the largest such machine in the
world until the large Hadron collider
was built in,
in Geneva,
but when it was being built,
he was called by Congress to testify and
he was asked will it aid in the defense
of the nation?
And he gave a beautiful statement,
but at the end of it was basically no,
it won't help aid in the defense of the
nation.
It'll just help keep the nation worth
defending,
uh,
that,
that actually is really beautiful.
I think it is.
So that's why I quote them.
So that's sort of it.
It's a problem of funding things in a
way because if you fund something,
people want results and what you're
saying is basically the whole
playground.
If science is entitled to that.
And it's a real problem now in
government funding and in the public.
People seem to want to fund things based
on,
in fact,
I wrote another piece on the House
Science Committee,
which basically wanting to require an
did to some extent scientists in their
grant applications to justify why what
they're doing is in the national
interest and the net doesn't necessarily
have anything to do with science.
Well,
the point is that it seems to me the
natural,
the national interest is an increasing
our knowledge and,
and it's not in.
And so if you,
if you require things directly to have a
practical application,
then you're going to miss almost
everything.
You,
it's already been well documented that
probably 50 percent of the current gross
national product of this country is
based on fundamental curiosity driven
research that was done a generation ago.
Accidents,
you know,
discovery of penicillin.
They weren't looking for antibiotics.
So even the development of transistor
wasn't.
If,
if people had said we need to make
better computers back at the time when
they were using wheels and other things
and they would have missed the use of
transistors.
So all of the things that have changed
our lives,
even the worldwide web,
which was developed at at Geneva,
the home of the large Hadron collider to
help scientists communicate in large
experiments when you have 10,000
scientists around the world,
it was important for them to be able to
exchange results without worrying about
where the results were and being able to
communicate.
That's what developed the worldwide web.
And of course that changed the world.
So you need to support fundamental
curiosity driven research.
If you stop doing that,
then not only do we suffer as a species
by law,
not our learning going not increasing,
but ultimately the spinoffs that are
going to change our lives are not gonna
occur.
Yeah.
So you mentioned Carl Sagan before and
my,
my scientific awakening was a little
slow.
I hate to admit it,
I was always into Scifi when I was
growing up and star wars and all that
stuff,
but my real scientific awakening,
I saw the movie contact and I'd eaten
pot brownies before and I thought I was
going to see,
I think air force one,
but it was sold out.
So I just went into,
I had no idea what it was about,
it didn't really know much about cross
Hagen,
but you know,
the opening Panorama universe in my mind
on pop round,
he's,
I mean,
it exploded.
I sensitive,
right?
Every Carl Sagan Book and all that.
Kind of what,
what was that moment for you?
I suspect it was a lot younger than it
was.
It was.
I was a little younger and a lot earlier
because a lot older.
But I'm actually,
you know,
well I,
I,
it's hard.
I'm not sure there was an epiphany in
that way,
but there was a.
But the first thing I can remember was
when I was in grade six,
I'm reading a book about Galileo and um,
and,
and it seemed romantic and remarkable to
me.
The fact that he was the first one to
look up that the moons of Jupiter and it
changed everything and,
and also the courage he had at or,
or lack thereof at times to,
to confront conventional wisdom.
That seemed to me to be a romantic
adventure that captured my imagination.
And that's probably one of the reasons
why write books is because it was books
about him and then books by people like
Isaac Asimov,
well before Carl Sagan and George Gamma
of and Albert Einstein,
and then Richard,
Richard Feynman books by people like
that got me excited as a young person
about the romantic adventure to be the,
to to be the first to understand
something new about the world.
And,
and so I returned the favor and I'm old
enough now that it's for me,
very satisfying.
Although a little depressing to think
how old I am and what I mean.
Scientists now say,
you know,
I read the physics of Star Trek and
that's what turned me on to be with
scientists.
So,
um,
but it was those popular books and I,
and that's why,
although it takes time out of,
out of my research directly,
it,
I'm not sure which is more useful in the
long run.
And besides I don't have control.
I have to do what I have to do when
writing.
It's one of them,
but,
but it's very satisfying to be able to
connect because the importance of a
university or of the research enterprise
is two fold.
And that's one of the reasons why my
origins project is twofold.
University Research University should be
based on the creation of knowledge,
but if you don't disseminate the
knowledge,
it's impotent so it has to be to,
to fold.
And,
and so,
uh,
I like to be involved in both for some
reason.
Yeah.
So the origins project,
you're trying to figure out the origins
of humans and the universe and we're
looking at the origins of everything.
It's [inaudible].
It's a wonderful playground because we
look at everything from the origins of
the universe to the origins of life to
the origins of violence and,
and,
uh,
um,
we're,
we're having,
we're having and the origins of the
future,
we're having a workshop,
uh,
in,
in February and the AI and its
challenges.
So if you think about it,
forefront questions,
there's a relationship always between
the future and the past.
And forefront questions are always based
about the origin.
What's the origin of disease?
What's the origin of of intelligence and
so as a curious person,
I can go well beyond just my area of
physics,
which tends to be more related to the
origin of the universe,
when which has gotten me into it,
to all these other questions.
I'm like a kid in a candy shop.
I get to meet and work with the most
interesting people in the world and
learn a lot about a lot of things.
So it's just,
it's really self indulgence,
which is most of my life is based on,
but it's bringing a lot of good to a lot
of people.
Me Self indulgence and individuality is
good.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
that's the other thing I guess I want to
say is that most people become
scientists not because they want to save
the world.
It's because they like doing it.
It's fun and,
and there's nothing and that's fine.
I,
I tell kids,
that's when they asked me what they
should do.
I say,
do what you enjoy because if you don't
enjoy it,
you're not going to do well anyway.
But I do science,
you know,
it's great if it has an impact in one
way or another,
but I do it because I enjoy it and,
and that and I and I am an unabashed
about that.
Yeah.
So I'm very proud that on this show,
which I try to bring on people of all
kinds of beliefs and political
persuasions and all that stuff.
I get tons of emails from religious
people even though they know that I'm
not a believer in that stuff,
so we don't have to dive too much into
the atheism thing.
But can you,
how about you give me the best sell job
in like three minutes on,
on the big bang,
like just something that someone that,
that is a believer of religion could
say,
well maybe there's something here.
Maybe there's some.
Well the point is it's,
it,
it's,
it's sad that I have to do that because.
Did I leave too much with that question?
Maybe I should untangled them.
No,
no,
no.
But I mean,
one,
it makes it sound like the big bang is
on a different footing than the fact
that the earth is round.
It's not the big bang happened.
Same with evolution.
It's not,
you know,
people get hung up in the word theory.
Well,
you know,
someone just wrote me and said,
well,
you know,
it's a theory.
And I said,
well,
gravity is a theory too,
so if you don't believe in walk up to
the 10th floor window.
But the point is a theory in science
means it's been tested theories a very
high level in science.
It means it's satisfied the test
experiment over and over and over again,
and the fact that the universe began,
that the universe was smaller than it is
today and smaller and smaller and
smaller and was once contained in a
microscopic region.
13 point 8 billion years ago.
That expanded dramatically is,
is,
is a fact.
And it and everything we sit,
we recognize about the university is
only understandable in that context.
There are lots of independent ways to
measure the age of the universe.
And we come up with 13 point 8 billion
years.
We measure the fact the university
expanding,
working backwards,
it was smaller than it is and if we
extrapolate back and say what happened
when the smaller we make predictions
about things that we hadn't seen before,
people say evolution or the Big Bang our
historical science because no one was
around.
They offer.
I mean no one was around to know,
so how do you know?
And I say,
well the point is all sciences
historical because all science is based
on explaining some observations but
done,
but then making predictions of things
that haven't been done and both
evolution and the big bang make
predictions about things that weren't
seen before.
If,
if the big bang happened,
we predicted it was predicted.
Although a lot of sciences didn't know
about it until after the fact that there
should be a universal background of
radiation coming at us.
That was once 3000 degrees in
temperature.
That's now three degrees.
That's been measured with exquisite
prediction.
Exquisite precision.
Sorry.
And also we predict that 25 percent of
the universe should be helium and almost
75 percent of the industry of the
hydrogen and one part in 10 billion new
universe will be lithium.
We go out and measure that 10 orders of
magnitude.
So we make tons of predictions of
things.
That's what science is,
not just a story like religion.
It makes predictions and if those
predictions don't agree with the
observations,
they're wrong.
So we throw the,
we throw it out like yesterday's
newspaper.
So the history,
that word historical science,
which a lot of fundamentalist use to try
and discredit evolution,
the big bang is nonsense because they're
not historical anymore than anything
else.
They make predictions about observations
that are gonna be made in the future.
And every observation we made about the
university's consistent only with that
picture and inconsistent with any other
ideas.
Yeah.
So you would say the evidence that we
have for the big bang is as much
evidence as we have.
The dinosaurs existed,
right?
It's just a different that we have
physical.
Moreover,
we have evidence that dinosaurs didn't
exist when humans,
humans exist,
no matter what they show in that is
wrong,
is that it's easy to say,
yeah,
I've been there.
I would there the day it opened.
And how you feel about that.
It was a remarkable experience.
I was there that they opened.
I,
I flew to Cincinnati and then into
Kentucky on the other side.
Where was that morning to lead to be the
keynote speaker at a protest that
morning.
And then um,
at,
because it is,
it,
it's,
it's that willingness.
The Saturn,
it's child abuse.
The idea is okay,
they believe something and,
and therefore they don't want kids to
know what really happened.
They don't want kids to know that
evolution happened because somehow it
might reduce their faith in God.
And so the idea that you want your kids
to not know how the universe works
because for fear that the loser faith is
no different than the Taliban when they
won't teach the kids anything but,
but memorizing the Koran and,
and,
and so it's,
it's worse than ignorance.
It's,
it's,
it's child abuse.
So W,
so I went there and protested and then I
actually,
I had credentials,
I was a commentator for NPR and I went
up to the right afterwards and they
recognize me and they said,
oh,
Professor Kraus,
your credentials didn't arrive.
You can't go into the museum.
So I said,
that's okay.
I happen to have a crew from pbs and,
and BBC are that are following me right
now.
Do you mind if they filmed me not being
allowed in the museum?
And then I got,
I got a tour by at that time,
the vice president of museum.
And it was,
it was,
it was shocking.
It's an amazing.
They do a bait and switch.
It was amazing.
And um,
uh,
they start out quite upfront in saying
reason and faith.
They brought it in the front door,
reason to faith why should,
and they point out that the two are
different and then they,
and they,
and they are,
you should believe in reason,
you should believe in faith.
And then,
and then they halfway through the
museum,
they make it seem like a natural history
museum.
So they do this bait and switch and uh,
but the,
but it's hysterical because they have
the garden of Eden With Adam and eve
both politically correct.
Adam is in grass up to here and eve has
hair down to their,
but they have dinosaurs,
you know,
in the garden of Eden of course.
And they trying to source wrecks,
you know,
is there,
it's got sharp teeth.
Why everything was a vegetarian in the
garden of Eden.
You may not have realized that but,
but if you go to the museum will
discover that and it's so they could
open pineapples so they could eat.
That's why the tyrannosaurs rex had
sharp teeth.
Wow.
You know,
I knew I was going to learn something.
There you go with you here today.
I'm glad that that will end up being.
All right.
We will.
We only have a couple minutes left.
I'm curious,
do you find that you have colleagues
that believe in everything that you just
said there are,
you know,
everything that we've talked about,
the,
the ideas of everything you've said,
but at the same time,
are there some people that do take the
leap of faith?
Oh,
sure.
Then believe in things that aren't
quantifiable at the same time.
Yeah.
For the first,
by the way we should say as scientists,
we should never use the word belief.
I know.
No,
I mean,
I mean it's just.
I fall into that trap to believing is
not part of science is is it likely or
unlikely,
and that's the question.
Yeah,
but of course their religious
scientists,
but as I like to say,
there are scientists who are
Republicans.
I mean the scientists,
believe it or not,
are human beings and human beings are in
some sense hardwired to believe to
mutually inconsistent things.
At the same time,
I often say that we all have to believe
in impossible things before breakfast.
Just to get up in the morning,
you have to believe you like your job or
your spouse or whatever.
Yet we all invent stories to go by and
so,
uh,
there are scientists religious as long
as they don't let that religious faith
interfere with their work,
it doesn't matter and the good
scientists so that way,
but,
but the,
making the claim that there are
scientists who are religious does not
mean that they're compatible.
Neither does making the claim that
science derives from religion because it
does,
I mean,
but in the history of West,
at least all of universities were once
religious institutions because as I like
to say,
the 17th century,
the church was the national science
foundation was the only plate.
If you want it to get money,
then that was the place to get it if you
want it to support your ideas.
So it's not too surprising that science
grew of religion.
But as I also like to say and again to
plugged set in the APP and to say it in
the new book,
that children often move away from their
parents.
Okay.
And so,
so talking about the background does not
mean that that science and religion are
compatible because they're not there.
They're not compatible in the sense of
being compatible with the specific
doctrines of the world's great religions
sciences and incompatible with a vague
notion that there might be purposed to
the university.
There is no evidence of it whatsoever,
and there's no need for a god.
As I showed in my last book,
there's no need for even supernatural
stuff to create a whole universe,
but science can't disprove the notion of
some vague datey.
Okay,
but what I can say is,
you know the earth didn't stop when
someone blew a trumpet and there wasn't
a virgin birth and all of those things
that's incompatible with what we know
about the universe.
All right?
We have two minutes left is one thing
that people aren't thinking about,
that you were a theoretical physicist.
You're thinking of something on a day to
day basis that the average person is not
thinking about.
Give me something that we.
Shots of things that we should be
thinking about that we're not.
Well,
I don't know whether we should,
but something something fun is that the
m is the future of the universe.
Is is different than we might believe it
might be.
In fact,
we may be living at a very special time
in the history of the universe.
And,
and,
uh,
when it turns out that what we've just
discovered about the Higgs Boson tells
us that everything we see in the
universe may be unstable,
that that matter as we know it could not
immediately.
So don't go ahead and sell your stocks
or anything,
but that in the far future that not only
we know the rest of the universe will
disappear because it's already expanding
away from us faster than the speed of
light.
At least it's receding from us faster
than the speed of light.
So the and,
and so the longer we wait,
the less we'll we'll be able to see if
the universe.
But it turns out that like an icicle on
a window or on ice crystal on a window
and a summer morning will eventually
melt.
The Higgs field that is allowing
everything we now see to exist could
eventually melt in a different kind of
way.
And if it does,
then matter as we know it will
disappear.
So we should enjoy our brief moment in
the sun so it's not going to happen
tomorrow.
No,
we're on the hairy edge of it.
It may never happen and we,
what we're trying to discover at the
large Hadron collider is will it
happened,
uh,
or,
or might it happen?
But even if it was,
we know it's not gonna happen for a heck
of a long time,
so there's time to try and make sure we
keep the present world working,
which means we have to vote responsibly
and ask yourself quit when you hear
something on TV.
It as,
as a former publisher of the New York
Times said,
and I use as my mantra.
I like to keep an open mind but not so
open to my brains fall out.
Alright,
well that's a perfect ending.
I hope you'll come back in March when
you do a proper press tour and.
Okay,
that'll be fine then I can promote you
again.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's good.
And it sometimes works it occasionally
or.
All right.
Well,
for more on Lawrence's work working,
there is a ton of it and he's written a
gajillion books.
I will put the link down to,
uh,
to the new book right below a checkout
crowd.
Stock Faculty that Asu Dot Edu.